the pittsburgh steelers had fallen and
they couldn't get up
and they finally got up down 24 7 in the
third quarter they found a way they they
flipped the switch they turned it on
they got it going they somehow
came back and beat the indianapolis
colts to number one
and a three-game losing streak number
two
win the afc north and let me just make
this observation
let's talk about this now okay i'm
thinking of it because there's a good
chance i'll forget
they seemed a little too
jubilant
about winning the afc north
the old hats and t-shirts moment it's
just look
in a year where there's only one buy
available and that thing went bye-bye a
couple of weeks ago when you fell into
the well that you've been trying to get
out of for three weeks
what does it matter what does it matter
to win a division championship when you
have no home field advantage tj watt
told me after the game they still have a
hard time finding energy in an empty
stadium hey they get to play a home game
in two weeks and do it all over again
try to find energy when there is no
external energy i mean i i was surprised
by
what tomlin said
after the game i was surprised by the
dancing in the locker room didn't the
saints lose a draft pick for what these
guys are doing that we see on screen i
don't know i may have to do my research
i think the saints lost i think they
lost a draft pick for it for dancing in
the locker room what what yes who when
did that happen i missed that that was
the that was that was the sean payton
the night that they trounced the tampa
bay buccaneers week nine the video
emerged of peyton and players dancing in
the tiny locker room at raymond james
stadium no you're right that's the road
locker room the home locker room in
pittsburgh as you see
much more spacious much more spacious
yeah much much more room but but yeah
the saints got in trouble for dancing in
the locker room eventually we lost a
late round pick and they gotta find a
bunch of money for it so anyway it just
seemed like a little bit too much of a
party atmosphere for doing what they
were expected to do a month ago okay
the bigger prize is the super bowl well
who cares about the division
championship you already were in the
playoffs it doesn't matter especially of
all years chris this year it doesn't
matter there's no benefit to it other
than you don't have to travel for your
playoff game all right hold on hold on
let me just get this down 704 monday
december 28th christmas did nothing he
is still the grinch okay um
december 28th is the key we've had this
exchange via text message december 28 is
a very bad day in the annals of the team
that i was cursed to choose to yeah for
when i was a kid dating back to 1975. so
hey here's the thing christmas is over
good will toward men that all expires
the time the clock hits midnight on
december 26th then it's back to being a
jerk again so i'm sorry yeah so
you know full disclosure we saw that on
text message already too so you know
come up with some new material here
today all right come on
but okay they're happy they won the damn
afc you know afc north championship it's
been a few years since they've won it
you know they've gone through some
things as a football team don't be mad
at them for that it's okay i mean
especially two within the fashion of
the way they won the football game and
the way they had looked the three weeks
previous to that yeah they had like like
the the ultimate proverbial monkey on
their back right i mean geez 11-0 is
this one of the best teams we've ever
seen you know we're we're getting crap
for not paying more homage to them on
the show and telling everybody how great
they are and then of course the world
fell out you know from under them there
and
it looked like it was going to continue
yesterday for two and a half quarters
you thought whoa it's the steelers are
done they're looking like it's going to
be one and done and they're out of the
playoffs they can't get their mojo back
and of course that changed and it
changed everything so i i can't be mad
at them for celebrating yeah okay you're
right would you play the starters would
you play the starters next week or give
them a buy because they haven't had a
buy all season long and what's the real
difference between the two seed and the
three seed remember they got ready for a
game against the titans week four they
ultimately didn't play it they haven't
had any real time off although a bye
week really isn't time off it's just
time where you're not getting ready to
play a game you're still working and
preparing but at least you're not out
there on sunday or saturday car crash
playing a game and getting yourself
banged up and having new injuries to
recover from would you rest starters if
you were mike tomlin i would rest the
defense that is for sure no matter what
i mean like you said hey you're getting
the home playoff game you don't know
really how this is going to shake out as
far as being able to play match-ups and
doing all of that so the defense mike
and i think you heard me during their
game yesterday it concerns me at times
because of their front four and how much
they have to play them all the time guys
like cam hayward and tuit uh and tj watt
they barely ever come out of the game i
mean ever they play almost every snap so
i would rest that side of the football i
do think that's a side that needs rest
offensively
i would have them go out there a little
bit mike probably you know they just got
it going a little bit let's see if we
can just keep you know the good momentum
going the execution going from where we
left off against the indianapolis colts
you know maybe we can tinker with
another idea or two in the passing game
uh as i said here on monday morning
that's probably the approach i would
have because the offense just got going
i wouldn't i wouldn't want to pull the
you know the rug out from underneath
them quite yet
the other concern is the health of ben
roethlisberger and there continues to be
a significant disconnect between what's
contained in the steelers three times
per week injury reports and the sunday
splash reports two weeks ago it was
jason lock and four of cbs saying
there's serious concern about both of
roethlisberger's knees i went back and
looked at the injury reports leading
into that sunday
no mention of his knees on the injury
reports yesterday it was ian rapport of
nfl media saying that ben roethlisberger
and weak thick 13 hyper extended his
knee well for every game after that
every week after that every injury
report after that
no mention of his knee so i don't know
what's going on here unless he's getting
treatment on his own or getting no
treatment at all because that's when as
a practical matter you end up disclosing
the injury when you have the guy go into
the treatment room and there is a record
that he has received some sort of
attention for that body part that's how
you get busted after the fact that's how
they got the jets for brett favre favre
going on and on trying to excuse how he
fell apart down the stretch in 2008
because he had a partially torn biceps
tendon they went back they saw the
records he'd gotten treatment they
hadn't disclosed it they whacked
everybody that's what the steelers would
be risking if he really is getting
treatment i think common sense suggests
either he isn't or he's getting it on
his own somewhere
if he truly is injured if these reports
are accurate but they're too persistent
to not be accurate so my point is
there's value in giving him a week off
and letting him heal up no i hear that
versus having him go out there and keep
throwing the ball down the field you're
right mike no that's it's a valid point
you're you're you're definitely not off
there you know i don't know how severe
that injury is uh just as the way it
looked yesterday the way he played in
the second half everything like that you
know if he is
somewhat close to a hundred percent i
would say yes let's continue and build
and grow on kind of what we did in the
second half of this football game
because it was the ultimate tale of two
halves i mean the first half was nothing
the the pittsburgh shielders couldn't do
anything the defense score
basically scored for them set the
offense up for a short drive
but but after that
there was nothing until okay the second
half starts big ben drives them down and
they get down to the one yard line and
it's like we've seen over the last few
weeks with the pitcher steelers right
mike i mean they get down there and you
just go well they can't run it in and
they're not going to score they don't
score
but luckily the defense pins them in and
from that point on
they pin the colts in gets good field
position and i don't know i mean big ben
and that offense just started clicking
it started being more aggressive down
the field i think that was the big thing
we both came away with from the game it
was we talked about all week they're
predictable last week and predictable
and the fact that they're gonna throw at
every play and then you know where
they're gonna throw it that's like a
double whammy at least yesterday we saw
them say hey screw these damn short
passes and these five yard dink and dunk
crap let's start to stretch the field
and it showed that it was effective
it's amazing the transformation that
finally happened right and the fact that
it took a 24 7 deficit against the colts
in the third quarter to finally wake the
steelers up and i know and am related to
a lot of steelers fans and they have
been going nuts lately get rid of ben
roethlisberger could he retire at
halftime it's like have you seen who
would take his place do you remember
last year do you really want to do that
again i don't think no and then there's
that segment of steelers fans that comes
out of the woodwork whenever they
struggle and says get rid of my tom and
get rid of my tom and get rid of mike
thomas like are you kidding me there are
members of the limited partnership the
minority owners that art rooney the
second who runs the team routinely
ignores but they will get riled up from
time to time about tomlin and the three
straight losses
that was causing more and more chatter
and then as of yesterday by half time
there were plenty of people who would
have loved to have seen a lot of folks
get run out of the building from the
locker room and told to never come back
so they really did
get themselves back on the right track
and i can understand the moment of
jubilation i just would say don't lose
sight of the bigger picture you've won
plenty of division titles they mean
nothing unless you do something in the
post season and my question
will continue to be
can they avoid one and done if they end
up facing the ravens in the wild card
round if they end up facing the titans
again in the wild card round can they
pull off a victory
and continue or will they be out of it
because look the colts we still don't
know where the cults fit sure but the
cults aren't as good as some of these
other teams especially right now that
the steelers gonna have to contend with
in two weeks you know you know maybe not
you're right i mean the cults are a
little bit all over the place yeah
definitely and of course the philip
rivers factor and him you know being a
little careless with the football and
all of that but i don't think pittsburgh
you know is gonna lose sight i don't i
think with what they've gone through the
last few years mike tomlin the leader he
is and then really the struggles of the
last few weeks and even yesterday
i don't think they're gonna walk into
the building today and just be like oh
man we can relax we're back like we're
back we're back to the 11-0 and 10-0
football team we were we're
indestructible no i they're still going
to walk in the building today realizing
one
okay we're in the afc
and at some point if we want to get
where we got to get to we're going to
have to deal with mahomey's and the
kansas city chiefs so that should keep
every anybody in the afc on edge at all
times to realize we need to get there to
get to that standard but i just think
with the last few years big ben's elbow
all that i have a hard time thinking
they'll fall asleep at the wheel mike i
i do and uh um i think yesterday kind of
proved that they can change the formula
and be effective
and maybe got their mojo back on the
defensive side of the ball and in the
passing game
and credit to mike tomlin he always
knows what his team needs and i think
the approach he took in the aftermath of
yesterday's win was calculated was
strategic was designed to be exactly
what he believed the locker room needed
right and now the challenge is get them
refocused and whether it's
12 days until the next meaningful game
or
six days until the next game when
they're out on the field in a
meaningless game for the most part other
than maybe the difference between number
two and number three which isn't a small
difference if you're talking about the
one seed eventually losing to someone
else and maybe you would end up hosting
the afc championship again this year
it's different because you wouldn't have
fans there if you're pittsburgh but i'm
going to defer to mike tomlin let's hear
from
the quarterback of the team that managed
to blow the 17-point lead on sunday
here's philip rivers talking about the
colts collapse in the second half in
pittsburgh
if you could have been in the stadium
there was a feel of with complete
domination in the first half all three
phases just kind of like that you don't
you all don't have an answer and we're
not going to give you an answer in the
second half it was like almost we we
gave them a glimmer of hope and then it
felt a little bit like we were hanging
on you know and obviously you say well
if you felt like you're hanging out wide
did you stop hanging on and just go push
the gas down maybe that's easier said
than done
and that's very real when you're in that
crucible when you're in that moment when
you feel it slipping away it's not like
there's a button you can press to stop
it it's you can't get off the ride at
that point you're in the middle of it
you're trying to figure out how best to
change it and there's only so much you
can do as you feel it slipping through
your fingers that's the way it works and
usually that all plays out in the
context of a completely full stadium and
they're waving the terrible towels and
as jim nance noted yesterday it was the
45th anniversary of the debut of the
terrible towel which came during a
playoff game against the colts in 1975
but even without fans there you can get
that sense and this happens in any
competitive setting right any
competitive setting when you know it's
falling apart there's nothing you can do
about it and there it fell apart the
final five possessions for the colts
starting with that stop they made on
their own two yard line that was the
moment where we should have said and
they should have said and they should
have behaved as if they delivered the
dagger to the steelers 24 7. they drive
down they go for it instead of taking
the field goal that should have been the
moment that it was over and instead
that's the moment that the steelers
defense rose up and and
dictated that
it was going to change and it was going
to end up going the home team's way yeah
it smothered them from that point on i
mean in a game where
that you know the colts up to that point
had pretty consistently moved the ball
all day long you know but yeah get them
backed up there big ben this is a little
out route right on fourth down you know
i you know didn't really drive it in
there threw it a hair late gets knocked
down they don't capitalize you go oh man
pittsburgh and these you know inside the
five yard line struggles but the defense
rises to the occasion which is why mike
tomlin felt comfortable going for it you
know i wasn't a big fan of going for it
there but there's a great example of a
coach knowing this football team because
i'm going you need the field goal at
some point let's get some momentum
pittsburgh and just make it 24-10 and
get down by two scores and have
something positive here for the offense
that happened you went geez but the
defense just came out
pissed off
three and out
punnett deonte johnson deep ball
bomb touchdown whoa here we go it's
24-14 and the defense continued to
smother to where in the first half the
colts were so balanced you know rivers
was really good and then of course when
they got first downs in the first half
and even in the first drive of the third
quarter it allowed them to stay with the
run game but they couldn't even get
involved in the run game to get a first
down and get the clock going and get the
chains moving there in the second half
to really get anything going at all and
then when they finally did
rivers 28 to 24
they're down they're six minutes it's a
first and ten and they're around
midfield and he throws
a deep post interception that you would
see a rookie throw it unfortunately just
happens too much with philip rivers this
day and age uh that really you know took
them out of having a chance to win the
football game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports